my name is Taryn Murphy I'm a junior
here at the college and I'm studying
philosophy and religion and I'm very
honored to introduce our speaker this
evening
Kimberly's Rasul writes the weekly
Potomac watched column for The Wall
Street Journal where she is also a
member of the editorial board a graduate
of Princeton University her previous
positions at the journal include news
assistant in Brussels internet reporter
in London commercial real estate
reporter in New York columnist for
opinion journal calm and senior
editorial page writer she is a regular
contributor to Sunday morning political
programs including Face the Nation and
Meet the Press in 2013 she was a Eugene
C Pulliam distinguished Visiting Fellow
in journalism at Hillsdale College and
in 2014 she was a recipient of the
bradley prize she's the author of the
intimidation game how the left is
silencing free speech and most recently
resistance at all costs how Trump haters
are breaking America please help me
welcome Kimberly stossel
good evening it is honestly such a joy
to be here every time I get to come to
Hillsdale it's a joy I want to thank
Hillsdale and the Center for
constructive alternatives for having me
here tonight just driving in last night
every time I come the growth and the
amazing changes at this place
we drove in last night and I said to my
husband I could swear that enormous
Chapel was not there when we were just
here a couple of years ago
yeah it's astonishing my one small
complaint it was funny last night and in
my bad by the way tea because I changed
my mind about this in the end as we were
driving here all these miles last night
I had this thought and it's the thought
that all over busy overbooked people
have when they're just trying to get to
a place right which is why eight is a
college that is so important to free
speech and to intellectual exchange and
so important to reminding us about the
history of the country and our founding
principles have to be located in the
middle of nowhere
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then I got here and and eased into
Hillsdale and had a glass of wine and
and of course the very obvious point hit
me which is that of course the reason
that Hillsdale has remained so committed
to free speech and exchange and to the
history and values of our country is
because it is located so far away from
every other population center all of
which have abandoned those values so
another way of saying well done and
please don't ever move anywhere else in
the country
I think Hillsdale may in fact be the
perfect venue to address a question of
wire we are seeing a resurgence of
socialism today and and bear with me
while I explain that when we talk about
the rise of the popularity of socialism
the polls show that it is mostly younger
Americans who are embracing it this is a
problem primary primarily albeit not
exclusively of youth which by the way
isn't necessarily a surprise it's kind
of like that old story there's a child
who says to their parent when I grow up
I want to be a socialist and the parent
replies okay but the problem with that
honey is that you know that you can't do
bowls
[Applause]
but the thing is writing this off as an
issue youth isn't good enough because it
obviously socialism isn't an innate
issue to youth it's difficult for
instance to imagine a socialist
philosophy sweeping a campus like
Hillsdale you know this is an
institution committed to providing its
students with facts history economics
the truth of the founding of this
country and the reasons for its success
as well as other examples of other
countries that have not fared as well
and all of this is allowed even the
youth of this campus to obtain a
realistic understanding of the dangers
of socialism it's also not good enough
though to just sit back and to assume
that the rest of the country's youth
those outside of Hillsdale will
inevitably grow up the problem is just
to urgent right now in the country there
are literally millions of younger
Americans to do today either openly
declare themselves socialists or say
that they have favorable view views of
that philosophy those young Americans in
turn have the ability to vote and to
vote ironically for much older
politicians who should know better who
should know their history and those
politicians in turn if given power are
promising policies that would radically
undermine the system of capitalism that
has served as the strength of this
nation since its beginning which leads
us to another old saying and something
that dr. Arnn alluded to earlier the
joke about any joke about socialism is
only funny when everybody gets it if we
want to know how to fix it though we
first have to understand the root causes
and we've had many capable academics and
sociologists and political observers now
document some of the structural shifts
that have arguably contributed to this
new interest in a very very dangerous
philosophy
globalization has led to greater levels
of wealth inequality and a new politics
of envy that globalization coupled with
over-regulation in the United States and
at times poorly managed trade policy his
displaced entire US manufacturing
sectors and hollowed out significant
swaths of the middle class ever-growing
government along side schemes like
gerrymandering has sheltered too many
politicians from accountability and left
millions of Americans feeling left
behind and more importantly alienated
from what they see as an elitist ruling
class and then we've had huge cultural
shifts as well too in this country those
younger Americans we were talking about
they aren't growing up they aren't being
asked to grow up they are living at home
until their 30s they're getting married
later putting off children putting off
buying a home all the things that
usually lead developing adults to be
more skeptical of government schemes and
government plans for redistribution by
the way I should just say in my house
one of the mottos is and I say to all my
children there are now 14 12 and 8 and I
say there's only one thing I can promise
will happen to you when you turn 18
years old and that is that your room is
going to be repurposed
[Applause]
but those those kids out there who do
dare to leave home are more and more
they're funneled into dead-end degrees
which lead to dead-end jobs in urban
areas where it's impossible to get ahead
impossible to buy a home and where they
are again surrounded daily by woke
liberal politics and policies that are
designed to pit American against
American now these shifts are very real
and very important but even identifying
them is not good enough because even big
cosmic structural shifts do not happen
in a vacuum
there are things behind them as well
they are the result of conscious
decisions trade doesn't just happen
it's negotiated regulation doesn't just
happen it's crafted political
unaccountability doesn't just happen it
is deliberate no one is making kids stay
at home until they're middle-aged the
decision to do so is a response to job
opportunities housing policies poor or
misguided education and rules that allow
their parents to continue funding their
health care until they are 26 years old
and so we can't just blame youth for not
knowing better it's like dr. Ernst said
earlier they're learning and they are
the product of parenting of education of
political policy and of culture so
instead I think that we have to
acknowledge that these shifts and that
the subsequent rise in the popularity of
socialism are in fact the result of
failures of core groups of officials and
civic institutions and tonight I'd like
to make the case that there are four in
particular that we need to talk about
and put out there for blame they are the
Democratic Party
the Republican Party the media and our
system of education in particular higher
education Hillsdale of course excluded
so let's run through them let's look at
the Democratic Party some of its most
influential members of which have
adopted an outright socialist agenda
Bernie Sanders Elizabeth Warren
Alexander okay Jie Cortez I'm always so
proud when I can say that name her
entire squad but it's a lot more broad
than just those names as I point out in
the book I just put out this is the most
socialist Congress in the history of
this country following the 2018
congressional election some of you may
know nate silver's 538 blog and it
pointed out that in 2010 there were
about 1.5 progressives or liberal
members of congress for every blue dog
moderate in the house right now
post the 2018 election the progressives
currently outweigh the moderates in the
party 4 to 1 and just a quick note I
think we should make about terms
progressivism let me stay right now is
socialism progressivism is that new word
that just burst into the political
ideology in recent years the question is
why did we need a new word the
Democratic Party's always had liberals
that's always had moderates and that has
always adequately described the party
and where it stood and it's in it splits
we have this term today because there
was a recognition just a few years ago
on the left that they needed a term to
describe a philosophy that went far
beyond the traditional liberal views of
higher taxes and bigger McGovern and
creative judges and what is that
philosophy I would say look at the plans
being advocated by Bernie Sanders and
Elizabeth Warren they would encourse
sectors of the economy eradicate
capitalism and replace it with
government-run tyranny health care
the best example as for other sectors
their plans would so radically regulate
core sectors of the economy finance
transportation energy to name just a few
as to essentially make them arms of the
government and they would also so tax
all of these sectors and businesses to
such a degree that they would cease to
even function to be half took to
function on the behalf of shareholders
they would instead exist as the central
means by which the Sanders and Warren's
and AO C's of the world would
redistribute wealth in this country does
everyone in this room I'm sure most of
you are aware of it of that famous
description of political and economic
systems is based on two cows some of you
have probably heard this so feudalism
you have two cows and your Lord takes
some of the milk fascism you have two
cows the government takes both of them
and hires you to take care of them and
sells you the milk a dictatorship you
have two cows government takes both and
then it shoots you my favorite was
always British democracy you have two
cows and they both go mad
[Laughter]
American capitalism you have two cows
you sell one you buy a bull and you grow
a herd and you hire workers and then you
go public and then you get on the Forbes
500 socialism you have three cows
government takes two and gives them to
other people
on the grounds that that makes things
fair this is pretty much the approach of
most of today's progressives in the
Democratic Party they would take the
majority of other people's wealth the
majority of other people's warnings the
majority of other people's property to
pay for free health care for free
education for free childcare for free
drugs so please don't be fooled by
Bernie Sanders tortured attempts to make
a distinction between democratic
socialism and pure socialism socialism
has long predated even communism and in
fact it's always existed in a variety of
forms if you look out there Marx and
Engels in their communist manifesto they
actually devoted an entire section to
criticizing the forms of socialism that
existed at the time that were not pure
enough for them what they didn't like is
that there were I've always been
socialists who believed in some aspects
of the market who believed in some
property rights who believed that people
should be able to keep a bit of what
they make those who have attended here
the past few days have heard some
wonderful explanations of the different
models of socialism around the world and
so let's be clear what progressives are
advocating today is just another version
of socialism it'd be a US version sure
but it's still socialism it's a version
in which some markets would actually be
allowed to exist in which some Americans
and corporations and wealthier people
would be allowed to keep some of what
they earn but they would to be clear by
and large be working for the benefit of
everyone else that is socialism and the
only reason the adherents to this
philosophy do not use that word openly
beyond Bernie Sanders is because they
know that
remains a detestable idea for most
Americans so instead we get the word
progressivism or we hear Elizabeth
Warren actually say with a straight face
that she is a capitalist she can say
what she wants
progressivism is socialism so the bigger
question is why have so many in the
Democratic Party moved left so quickly
younger people in this country who are
adopting socialism at least have the
excuse of being ignorant of history they
are seemingly unaware that if we in this
room had a dollar for every time
socialism was successful
we'd have zero dollars of course what's
more notable is that even if socialism
did work we'd all have zero dollars to
here also unfortunately seemingly
unaware and more importantly of the
extraordinary cruelty and devastation
that pure forms of socialism have
wrought socialism has over hundreds of
years meant the end of free speech free
assembly a Free Press free religious
belief free elections and a free
judiciary it's more communistic versions
have resulted in imprisonment execution
starvation of tens of millions of human
beings look at the histories of Russia
China Korea Cuba Cambodia Vietnam
Ethiopia and more recently Venezuela the
list is long and it's horrifying and
right there in the history books in
black and white for all to see so what
excuse to older wiser members of the
Democratic Party have for embracing such
an inexorably disastrous course they
know the history and so I say in light
of that I think we have to adopt a more
cynical view of their motives
so I premise here that their interest is
not necessarily just equality and higher
standards of living or the betterment of
a free society because we all know from
the history books that that's not what
you get
I would argue that their motive at least
in part is the same motive that has
propelled so many of the socialist
drives of the past its power and its
control most parties if you think about
it when their message fails to resonate
with the public when they lose say a
presidential election they decide to
take a step back like their wounds do an
autopsy figure out what they did wrong
and come back the next cycle and do it
better
unfortunately this has not been the
habit of the Democratic Party over the
past 10 years political setbacks have
not been met with hard thought they've
instead been met with an attitude of how
do we shackle the other side and how do
we change the system to make it easier
to win during the Obama years we had a
new era for instance of intimidation in
which Democratic officials trained the
federal bureaucracy on their opponents
inspiring the IRS to target conservative
groups engaged in political activity we
had liberal prosecutors and attorneys
across the states launch criminal
investigations into their political
opponents in Wisconsin and Montana and
New York we've seen new speech codes on
campuses and in the age of Trump this
tendency is only grown the attitude of
the resistance again the focus of my
book I'm just making a little pitch here
because we're a capitalistic audience
is that this president and the
Republicans are illegal occupiers of an
office and that therefore any action in
justifying that is justified in removing
them from that position and so we've had
an unprecedented FBI counterintelligence
investigation into a sitting
presidential campaign think about those
words we've had the most raucous and
ambush attack on a Supreme Court nominee
in history Brett Kavanaugh we have
watched House Democrats pass as their
first piece of legislation and the
majority starting this year a new voting
reform that would pave the way for fraud
at every level of the ballot box and we
are right now witnessing an
unprecedented use of impeachment as a
partisan political tool these are all
extremely dangerous new uses and abuses
of what are meant to be solemn powers
exercised by solemn institutions and
they will potentially have profound
consequences for our democracy going
forward in the last election Hillary
Clinton actually ran on promoting a
constitutional amendment that would have
overturned citizens united and given
politicians the ability to define what
was appropriate political speech think
about that idea we have a OSI I'm not
going to try your name a second time
right now attempting to bully Facebook
into not running ads from one political
party and we have candidates like
Senator Warren calling for the abolition
of the electoral college for the packing
of the Supreme Court so let's be clear
anyone who has even a passing
understanding of the glorious history of
our electoral college of the beauty of
that system that our founders created
would never contemplate advocating its
destruction the electoral college was
set up as a reflection of our republic
as a guard against pure majority rule
and those who are now pushing a change
or an end to it are not doing so because
they believe in a better country come on
they're doing so for
/ tusen power they want to be in control
and then stay in control forever and
these political actors understand that
socialist policies are a further Avenue
for obtaining and keeping that power
progressives can say that they're
interested in fairness and healthcare
for all and better education maybe that
is what motivates them to some part but
here's the thing they also know that
those policies provide them
extraordinary new political power and
control over speech over assembly over
money over elections giving government
control of our healthcare literally
means giving government control over
life and death
giving government control over energy
gives government control over what
people drive what jobs they can have
where they can travel and what food they
can eat and if you don't believe me go
look at the text of the green new deal
in which they're honest about the
decisions that they intend to take on
behalf of the electorate they know from
history that these schemes do not lead
to more equality or to a better world so
we have to assume in the end that a big
part of this is instead about obtaining
raw political power taking it and
keeping it and in the process they're
taking advantage of those millions of
young Americans who have experienced
those structural shifts I mentioned
young Americans who are demoralized by a
global economy struggling at times for
jobs overloaded with student debt unable
to buy a home
they are pandering to those young
Americans basis instincts the world
isn't fair it's stacked against you the
rich are keeping you down I'll pay for
your health care I'll pay for your
education
I'll penalize those who would charge you
for a mortgage or a credit card or a
prescription drug these politicians are
not lifting them up they're not
inspiring them to do better they're
capitalizing on fear
and weaknesses and worries this is a
failure of leadership by people who know
better who have an obligation to
acknowledge history to celebrate u.s.
successes and use their power with
humility and restraint so that's the
Democrats
but I would point out that the failure
isn't just on the liberal side this
opportunity to pray exists because too
many of us on the conservative side have
not done a good enough job at combating
it when we simply haven't we have to
acknowledge that
[Applause]
everyone young and old needs principles
around which to organize their lives
young Americans are every day hearing
the socialist call as I mentioned your
life is to dot tough the deck is stacked
against you you need us to lift you up
government can do that and they are not
hearing a compelling message to the
contrary conservatives in in particular
the elected members of the Republican
Party are failing in that regard and the
biggest failure is simply one of
messaging and it's a failure born I
would wager from conceit here's a
problem with conservatives we innately
understand the beauty of free markets
and free people so much so that we can't
imagine that nobody else does and we
don't think we need to take the time to
explain it to them and sometimes by the
way conservatives are understandably
further discouraged by the need to
tackle what are very complex subjects
and the world in which we live of
30-second sound bites that's a hard
thing to do it is after all much easier
for progressives look at those
Democratic presidential candidates
calling for the abolition of the
electoral college they have a very
simple message it's not fair a majority
of Americans voted for Hillary Clinton
she ought to be President when was the
last time you heard a prominent
conservative leader take the time to
explain why the Electoral College
matters so much its history and its
principles to explain the importance of
guarding against pure Democratic
majorities the importance of encouraging
coalition building and nationwide
campaigning the importance of us as a
republic would anyone like to actually
hazard a guess of how many young
Americans under the age of 30 even
understand how the electoral college
works raise your hand do you think is
like 10% that's an extraordinary failing
they don't and by the way those who do
might entirely be here
this campus let me give you a working
world example of how this failure works
in practice and how this failure also
greases the wheels for socialism I
remember a particularly brilliant
senator by the name of Tom Coburn from
Oklahoma some of you might know him he
was an obstetrician by trade and he was
a true what I call citizen legislator
meaning he came relatively briefly to
Washington to help better his country
and to benefit by sharing his knowledge
in particular his knowledge of the
healthcare system and after he spent a
little bit of time there guess what he
left and went back to his home senator
Coburn spent years exhorting his
Republican colleagues to make themselves
knowledgeable on the creeping costs and
growing problems in the health sector
what was driving it just how many
Americans were getting angry over it
what the response should be and his
colleagues by and large ignored him on
the Republican side he was told that
health care markets were complicated the
politics were complicated Republicans
risked alienating voters if they pushed
the wrong policy senator Coburn and
several of his colleagues actually
developed a model health care reform
based on free-market principles but none
of the Republicans and his conference
could agree to all of the different
elements so nobody in the end did
anything right up until the point that
an Illinois senator named Barack Obama
made fixing health care the centerpiece
of his 2008 presidential campaign and he
had a lot of Americans who were eager to
hear his ideas because they were fed up
with the status quo and he won on it and
he pushed through on the barest of
majorities Obamacare Obamacare has since
performed exactly as conservatives
predicted it would driving costs up even
further disrupting care undermining
innovation and making health care
unattainable for significant numbers of
Americans so much so that we now have
Democrats saying that the only way to
fix these problems
the problems that they created is to
socialized medicine and to put
government in control of all of it and
Republicans are doing the same thing
they were doing a decade ago they're
decrying those Democratic plans but even
today and let me stress this even today
they do not have a unified reform in
response 15-20 years later not with one
voice and not with one vision and so by
the way if you're one of those millions
of young Americans out there
it makes a choice in this election very
simple you can vote for Republicans and
get the status quo which nobody is very
happy with or you can vote for Democrats
and get free health care which would you
choose
given what's been told to you out there
in this environment so this too is a
failure a leadership but by a group of
elected leaders who need to do more than
just complain about the other side who
need to have the passion of their
convictions and the mindset that is
their obligation to teach and explain
and boldly tackle even complicated
subjects and moreover who need to start
coming up with a strategic plan for how
to break through the stranglehold the
stranglehold of the two other
institutions that are doing so much
damage to our country who are also most
directly in daily failing our young
Americans the media and the education
complex our press is currently overdue
for singular criticism for decades now
the media has been moving to the left
and this I believe is a function of a
growing elitism in the media profession
one that stomped out diversity of
viewpoint long gone are the days when a
farm boy could put himself through a
community college start as a cub
reporter at a local paper and one day
find themselves on a desk at the New
York Times increasingly the reporters
who shape our daily narrative from these
lofty media purchases all come from the
same left-of-centre communities all went
to the same leftist Center at colleges
all have the same left-of-centre abuse
by the way I grew up in a logging
community in Oregon I don't know a
single person who lives and works in
journalism today who hasn't even a
remotely similar experience to mine in
fact they actually wonder if we still
have electricity in the places where I
grew up it's it's just an they're so
divorced from anything outside of New
York or Washington it's something to
behold and meanwhile the old guard
editors who used to exist just
scrupulously stamp out hints abayas
are all things of the past and one
result is that most of the mainstream
media today actively campaigns against
capitalism and free markets in 2018
researchers from the Arizona State
University in Texas A&M University
surveyed 462 financial journalists okay
financial journalists these are the
people who have a special understanding
of markets finance corporations trade
these are the people who therefore ought
to have the most understanding of the
virtues of capitalism in particular by
comparison to any other system in the
world ever in all of history and yet the
researchers found that of these more
than 450 journalists nearly 60 percent
admitted to being very liberal or
somewhat liberal another 37 percent
described themselves as moderate and
precisely 4.4 percent said they leaned
right of center 4.4 percent this is why
the mainstream media uniformly writes
stories that are hostile to tax cuts to
deregulation to labor market freedom to
healthcare freedom and to political
campaign spending which by the way is a
form of free speech it's why they're all
so hostile to corporations and
businesses that employ tens of millions
of Americans if you are a millennial and
you take an even occasional interest in
the news this is the unrelenting message
that you are sent every day in addition
to this you are provided a never-ending
stream of stories about vulnerable
all communities who are unable to help
themselves without the aid of government
you also read fawning coverage of
socialist proposals offered by
Democratic candidates whether it be
Medicare for all or the green New Deal
free college the forgiveness of student
debt and these stories are also and I
think this is important not just fawning
but bereft of any critical analysis of
the failings of these systems failings
that have already been demonstrative
ruin in other countries that have
adopted similar proposals we never won
was the last time you read a story about
a Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
plan for Medicare for all that mentioned
the waiting lines or death panels that
accompany Britain's National Health
Service we hear nothing about the
collapse of medical innovation in other
countries that have instituted price
controls we hear nothing about the mess
that is currently the energy market in
places like Germany that have embraced
renewable energy programs of the very
type now being pushed by the American
Left this amounts and I'm saying this is
a journalist to professional malpractice
but it explains yes it is awful it is
not journalism anymore this is not
journalism but it explains why so many
young people are unaware of economic
realities our press corps is failing
them and I would just point out those
are just the factual questions they are
failing the country and an even bigger
and more scary way than just economic
illiteracy most socialist regimes are
accompanied by autocratic or
totalitarian tendencies and that is
because socialism as an economic project
is imposed from the top down the more
power you have at the top the easier it
is to force people to implement your
agenda and the guard against this has
always been a vigilant and Free Press
which exists to be skeptical of
government power to be on guard against
government abuse that press in turn
leads to a more educated active
citizenry that rises up against real or
even
perceived abuses of power in the past
three years our press has completely
abdicated that role the press has gone
beyond mere bias to actively and overtly
joining one side in a partisan war and
so visceral is its hatred of this
current president that it has abandoned
all of its basic standards and functions
this is a press corps that for the past
three years has praised and justified an
FBI investigation into a presidential
campaign
imagine that Jim Comey's FBI engaged in
Hoover like behavior surveilling members
of a political campaign keeping secret
memos of his conversations with the
president leaking them later to gin up a
special counsel not only is oppressed
blessed this behavior it has sat and
served as a willing scribe for the
self-serving narratives of those who
were actually fired from their jobs it's
put them on TV serving them up as
neutral analysts on these topics the
very people who were at the center one
of the greatest political scandals in
modern times when I was coming up
through journalism you were taught to
question anything a government official
told you to look out for spend these
guys are acting as the narrator's of
that former institutions leadership
positions and there is a generation of
younger Americans who have been told for
three years as a result that there is
nothing wrong whatsoever with powerful
law enforcement and intelligence
agencies secretly monitoring American
political figures we have a press corps
that these days routinely tells that
younger generation that it's okay for
Americans to settle their political
differences via impeachment for one
party to overturn the results of an
election because they don't like those
results we have a press corps that tells
the younger generation that it's okay to
ambush a Supreme Court nominee with
uncorroborated allegations of sex
we'll assault and gang-rape and to put
forward those allegations despite no
evidence and in contravention of all
basic principles like due process or the
standards of innocence until proven
guilty we have a press corps by the way
a press corps that exists because of our
Constitution and the First Amendment
that tells our younger generation that
it is right and indeed good for campuses
to have speech codes and safe spaces our
press corps says this and in light of
all this of the failure to report
honestly on the failings of socialist
economics and of the daily justification
they put forward of abuses of power how
can we ever expect that younger
generation to have a dim view of abuse
of power or socialism especially to and
this brings us to our last this is
really a glum speech isn't it sorry
I have some optimistic points at the end
okay
especially to given the education
they're receiving okay
the important part of the speech it
starts in grade school and whether your
complaint is poor education or
incomplete education or biased education
the problem is the same by the way I
have kids at all levels of school high
school middle school and grade school by
the way just shoot me having kids in
three different schools is awful and I
love the fact that they all learn about
our civil rights era it's really
important but I think that many of us
out there would be equally grateful if
our children were also provided in an
equivalent amount of study about the
founding of this country or the horrific
histories of other countries from the
Soviet Union to China the followed
socialist and communist pass and we
would be equally grateful if we had
schools that managed to teach even half
of our children to adequately read and
write by the time they leave high school
because by the way that is not the case
today and if we're going to talk about
our obligations of our younger
generation to understand the failings of
socialism's children who cannot
adequately read or write cannot be
expected to take reasoned decisions
about choices of economic systems when I
go out these days and people ask me what
they think what I think is the biggest
issue facing this country I used to be
conflicted on that I'm not anymore and
so my first answer is always higher
education and it simply is you know even
when I attended college which is really
a long time ago now our places of higher
learning were already straying away from
the Western Canon from the great books
they were becoming captive to grievance
politics so even when I went to college
at Princeton University in my particular
course of study and we were one of the
first years that had to do this I was
not allowed to graduate unless I took
what was called a disadvantaged persons
course
I'm not really sure if I'm proud or
embarrassed to say that it was the only
requirement I fulfilled Princeton
University as a film course a my
overriding memory of that class beyond
getting to watch shaft which by the way
I did think was really cool and very
entertaining was it we didn't learn a
great deal
beyond anger it was a course that was
designed to stoke discord to dredge up
animosity to Pitt student against
student and I really didn't see the
point but that was at least just one
course that I took at university and I
survived it for most students today
these ideological agendas are the bread
and butter of their college experience
they are an hourly experience our
universities are almost uniformly
liberal if not outright socialist in
their classes and in their teachings our
professors who are hired and then
protected under tenure lecture our
students daily about an American society
that is racist sexist Aegeus corporatist
and elitist these kids are told that the
entire world is rigged against them and
that the only remedy for such a
situation is more government that will
protect and equalize society three years
ago the econ Journal watch did a study
of more than 40 leading universities and
questioned more than 7,000 professors
liberal professors outnumbered
conservative professors by a ratio of
twelve to one and by the way the left
finds even that ratio intolerable in the
last book I wrote the intimidation game
I wrote about an organization which some
of you may have heard about called
uncock my campus so you may know the
Koch foundation the two libertarian
brothers one recently passed away over
the years has made an effort to start up
programs of intellectual debate and
free-market on campuses intellectual
debate this is what colleges exist to do
but know there is a group of Americans
out there who do not want that debate so
when the foundation chooses a university
to start a program the
coke my campus Network which is backed
by labor unions and environmental groups
and liberal activists it organizes
individuals to protest and to tar any
professors who might work at such a
program they file state four-year
request to get a hold of documents and
they try to embarrass universities out
of allowing these programs to exist on
their campuses now I would point out you
do not see such efforts to stops a
billionaire Tom Steyer from starting a
program at Stanford as he did recently
that was entirely devoted to the study
of climate change
that kind of billionaire underwriting is
apparently okay but now what comes to
billionaires supporting ideological
diversity we have an entire group that
is dedicated to making sure students are
not exposed to any thoughts beyond those
put forward by their socialist
professors I think to be even bigger
problem though and again this gets back
to what dr. urn was saying kids are
learning we will expect them to engage
in behavior that we do not always
approve of especially given all of these
influences around them all the time so
one of the biggest concerns is the
abdication of leadership among
university presidents faculty and staff
this is the real problem
universities that coddle infantile
myopic or destructive behavior you know
in the immediate wake of the election of
President Trump and I am NOT making this
up the University of Kansas urged
students to make use of therapy dogs the
University of Michigan comforted its
distraught students by handing out
coloring books and play-doh
no joke and I really hope Hillsdale does
not have a supply of play-doh anywhere
on campus across the country students
and even faculty ever bolted against
visiting conservative speakers staging
demonstrations engaging in violence by
the way the response to such behavior
ought to be a little bit like the story
we heard tonight it ought to be to
remind students that they are at a
university to learn that they are
expected to behave in a certain way and
that those who disrupt or protests the
noble pursuit of learning will be asked
to leave to surrender their spot to a
more open-minded scholar instead
university administration's bowed these
demands abandon intellectual diversity
and turn a blind eye to atrocious
behavior so again how can we expect our
students to reject and abhor socialist
and authoritarian impulses when the
leaders of their schools are encouraging
them to indulge in those impulses every
day now there are universities that give
us cause for hope places like Hillsdale
or places like I'm actually happy to say
my alma mater Princeton this might
surprise you
there are two professors of Princeton
Robby George who is a conservative and
Cornel West who is a liberal who many
years ago on that campus teamed up to
argue jointly that universities a must
be a place for open debate and a liberal
arts education and they every teen Lee
come together to press for civil debate
and true speaking on campus and that
Alliance has not only allowed a lot of
really great speakers to come to
Princeton University but it's also
allowed the university to feel confident
enough to hire more conservative
professors and it gives students on that
campus the beginning at least of
ideological diversity in their
classrooms we have to have this when I
went through school when many of us in
this room went through school we had
teachers and later professors on
different sides of the ideological
spectrum and it was crucial to us to
hear those opposing view opposing
viewpoints
these days our students are only hearing
one side and it's the song of socialism
moreover I should point out we parents
are actually paying for it we are paying
for them to be indoctrinated I know so
many parents these days who are simply
terrified of even sending their child to
a center of higher learning that's just
wrong so this is all by way of saying if
we care we really are worried about the
resurgence of socialism in this country
we have to look at the root causes and
we have to look at the bad actors our
country is always as good as its
information and it's teaching and it's
guardrails and right now our information
is poor our teaching is poor and our
guardrails are bent and broken
we need an informative neutral press
that is holding government and political
parties to one standard of political
accountability no matter what side of
the aisle they are on no double
standards we need an education system
that educates that explains to our
children the founding principles of this
nation and that embraces ideological
diversity and we need political parties
that look beyond Ron raw power and that
take the time to engage in considered
Civic debate so how do we do this so
this is a happy part of the speech I
think the good news is is that we can
okay we can I agree with dr. Arnn a
layer that we can do this I'm a
conservative it means I am an optimist
by nature and one thing that gives me
enormous optimism is that this
generation that we are discussing the
one that is currently somewhat in thrall
to socialism it is actually a perfect
audience for conservative libertarian
and capitalist ideas this is a
generation that hates in theory top-down
control they are skeptical of most forms
of power this is a generation that was
grown-up able to get an uber whenever
they want it and find any
Meishan at the touch of google they
start businesses in their parents
basements they crowdsource capital
investment they reject traditional
business structures you know unlike old
fogies like me who by the way has only
held one job in her lifetime and is now
rounding into her 25th year at The Wall
Street Journal
well like I'm saying they wouldn't
applaud alright they switch jobs they
leverage employers they're unafraid to
take risks these are the kids who are
and who should therefore reject promises
of government jobs and government
imposed equality or government navona
all that they're really lacking is the
information and the experience to
connect those political dots and the
other source of optimism we the people
still have the power to change things we
really do and we do so by embracing in
my mind one of those fundamental aspects
of capitalism consumerism you know
something I've always loved about this
country is just how demanding we are as
consumers at least in some regards I
still delight when I go to a diner and I
watch some like 80 year old guy like
take 20 minutes to look at his bill and
make sure no one charged on 50 cents
extra
for the extra bit of bacon on the side
and then you know painstakingly work out
what the 15 percent tip is and make sure
he doesn't give an extra penny I love it
when I go and I see consumers and the
returns line at store and they're
rejecting the toaster that doesn't get
quite hot enough or the blanket that
wasn't as fuzzy as was advertised on TV
or the kids toy that doesn't perform
exactly as a manufacturer said it would
and I think the trick for all of us is
being just as picky and just as
demanding in our accountability of our
institutions and politicians we must as
a society hold government officials
responsible for abusing their powers
cheapening solemn tools and institutions
and we must demand
that our elected leaders do a better job
of articulating their policies and their
responses to socialism explaining not
just why it's immoral
but why their own answers are better we
also have to demand more of our media
and when it fails to deliver sexuality
or history or truth or skepticism we
have to kill it turn it off
cancel the subscription turn off the
channel cut the cord whatever word you
want to use these days don't pay for it
and think we must and this is probably
the hardest part demand a lot more from
our colleges and universities and
graduate schools seriously many of you
are alumni at these schools we must be
involved we have to take part in those
board elections and those proxy
resolutions and those votes we have to
refuse to contribute until universities
recommit to intellectual diversity call
and write letters and make clear the
demands whenever I make these sort of
suggestions I'm often told yeah yeah
you're right but you know what it's just
really hard so time-consuming I have job
I have kids I have family obligations to
which I always like to respond George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson were
pretty busy guys too so are all of the
founders but they understood that only
through hard work would they create this
extraordinary republic of ours and so I
think as we go ahead we have to remember
those words of Benjamin Franklin it's a
republic if you can keep it thank you
thank you very much
you are an amazing audience
you know I just have to say by the way
you should be really proud of Hillsdale
for what it expects of its feature
speakers whenever I go to give a speech
III never just pull one out of a bottom
drawer and give the same one I always
feel responsible to write one for each
new group I go to but when I come to
Hillsboro I literally sweat I took like
three weeks writing that speech because
I'm like oh man this is such a
sophisticated audience you know and all
these fancy people are going to be there
and they're gonna call me out if I get
it wrong so and they'll never invite me
back so this was a hard one thank you
Thank You mr. Russell miss Russell has
agreed to sign copies of her book
resistance at all costs
how trump haters are breaking America
and that will be directly following the
lecture in the store lobby and right now
we have time for some Q&A so if you have
a question please make your way to the
microphone hello can I call you Kim you
may thank you you did a great job here's
my question
let's all assume and hope and pray that
Trump wins in 2020 I have been worrying
about 2020 for Kim for president thank
you no you know it was funny um I got it
was great I got to sit with John
Miller's journalism students today if
you don't know John Miller he runs an
amazing journalism project here
everything here is amazing he runs the
amazing journalism project and someone
asked me how I made my choice of going
into journalism and I said you know I
was really actually quite interested in
the beginning and politics and maybe
working in Washington or even running
for office after covering politics for
one year I said never never it's a
horrible life yeah maybe something that
doesn't really require running hi thank
you for your talk first of all and it
focused pretty strictly on government
and I was wondering your thoughts on
measures that are compatible with the
free market and Free Association like
workers cooperatives or consumer
cooperatives yeah so I mean I think they
can if they're centered around the idea
of free markets you know I think some of
the problems I've seen some of these in
bigger cities like New York City
etcetera and they have a more kind of
communist ik like everyone donates their
time it's just so I think that if you
look we're seeing this for instance in
health care markets and some of these
proposals for instance to have
small employers band together and sort
of pool basic costs but in a way that
sort of lowers their overheads and
allows them to keep more of their
profits and give more to their workers
these are great ideas and I think
there's a an enormous opportunity for
younger Americans who are part of this
whole new connected economy right now
we're seeing versions of it in uber etc
but there are ways to do that in amazing
new ways that could lower overall costs
help consumers but do so in a free
market way if I knew we're really
fascinating because of course it's
knocked up against it was started by
good-hearted liberals and it's marked up
like ended up getting knocked up against
all these unions that are like you can't
drive a bunch of drivers that aren't
unionized and and you know Silicon
Valley has had to deal with that
philosophical question but network
society's there's enormous opportunity
for free market younger Americans to
embrace this world that a lot of us
older people didn't really grow up in
and figure out ways to use it to to do
amazing things with capitalism hi mister
SL thank you so much for your talk I
agreed with you on a lot of things
tonight but one thing I liked I I'd like
to hear your thoughts on is when you
talk about the Democratic Party you you
you assigned more malevolent motives so
the lame yeah well well I was just I was
wondering if if we start assigning
motives to them of saying they're
actually in it for power and control
rather than taking them at face value
aren't we like losing kind of any common
ground we can have as soon as we start
assigning motives to people that they
won't admit to and like I'm sure there
are some bad Democrats like I totally
agree but if we just start
if we kind of lump them all together as
like power-hungry don't we lose a lot so
so look by the way I wouldn't lump them
all together I didn't put a OC in that
category of people that I think is
necessarily power-hungry I think she's
just
tragically misinformed and I think she's
28 and hasn't really had a lot of world
experience and I think she honestly and
scarily believes that you know we could
just get rid of all the airplanes and
all the cow farts and it would all be
good you know I just don't think but my
complaint and I tried to point it out in
here is Bernie Sanders knows better all
right and when he's asked a question out
there about Venezuela and says don't you
have a problem with what's happening in
Venezuela and the people that are being
shot in the street and the people who
are starving he goes it's not a
socialist country come on he knows
better and so that's the kind of
dishonesty and politics that I don't
like and I don't see how you can be I'm
sorry I'm speaking very freely here but
I don't see how you can be a politician
that say you believe in the betterment
of human beings with that experience
unfolding before your eyes and say that
is something the policies you want to
implement here in this country knowing
that that could be what happened so I
think that's disingenuous and I think
they need to be called out on it I mean
maybe he's misinformed too I just find
it harder to believe that you can be
that age and be that misinformed
[Applause]
but it's a good question and you're
right I think we need to have some basic
kind of places where we get together I
do yeah I've been running on this side
oh I think wandering over the years
seems we are the West is committing
suicide so we had this AOC lady with a
new green deal somebody pointed out
impracticality says you message yourself
she said who cares it is the moral thing
to do what morality was she referring to
what is it the kind of morality that the
good guys we don't do not know how to
take away from them and in my appearance
the morality of altruism man has no
right to live for his own sake that is
the underlying morality that's
destroying us now am I wrong no you're
not and that was sort of what I was
trying to respond to this one is to this
other question is I mean the education
has so failed our students that not only
do they not know the history and what
has happened in the past but they've
also taught them to believe that you
know I can say my morality is right
everyone else's morality is wrong and I
will impose my viewpoint I mean that
somehow is moral to impose my viewpoint
on you no matter what else III think
that's astonishing I think she hasn't
again I think she just is a person that
hasn't had a lot of doesn't have a lot
of knowledge and doesn't have a lot of
experience but unfortunately has a great
deal of arrogance and unfortunately
worse has a great deal of power and that
is very disturbing to me it's why I talk
about accountability I thought one of
the most amazing things that was said
this year because it was so honest and I
don't even think Nancy Pelosi realized
she was being so honest she was asked to
say something about the squad this was
back before she made nice see with them
and she was a little bit mad AOC and she
said you know well AOC can say anything
she wants because honestly in her
district you could have run a glass of
water with the letter D after the
and it would get elected and her point
that she was trying to make is that some
Democrats come from more competitive
districts and they can't afford to be
insane but in doing so she exposed one
of the fundamental problems that I
mentioned in this speech is that we have
too many politicians that are
unaccountable to the electorate do you
know that every year 435 seats are up
for election in the House of
Representatives and about 40 of them are
competitive 40 everything else is so
gerrymandered that not one of those
people has to worry about their
reelection so of course that encourages
people to take extreme positions
Alexandria okay zo cortezes only concern
was beating the Democrat in her primary
election there was never any question a
Republican could have any possibility of
ever winning that seat and so she wasn't
challenged on any of her views and now
she comes and the TV cameras are on her
and she is suddenly hugely influential
we can't allow our politics to operate
this way yes hi I loved your lecture but
I had a question you were talking about
education and stuff and intellectual
diversity and this is not something I
agree with
I'm just kind of arguing from the other
side a lot of people would say that
Hillsdale is not entirely neutral when
it comes to politics and education and
kind of the world view we kind of put
out to the students who come here so
what would you say makes Hillsdale
different and not just doing the same
thing all the other schools are doing
just flipped
so does Hillsdale I mean here's a
question I'm actually really curious
does Hillsdale prevent liberal speakers
from speaking here no we don't have yeah
but what would it ever prevent it no and
and would you feel as it like does it
print but forms of information coming I
mean I think one of the things that's
out there is the whole world
like every TV station is surrounded by
liberal politics and liberal and
presumably tons of you see that on your
phones and and nobody's taking away your
phones lately and things like no I mean
I think look I did the logical diversity
is simply important as a concept and I
have no doubt I mean just the journalism
class I was out today we talked about
things on left and right sides of so
that's the question is do you feel
confident I mean I guess one of the
questions is is a student does anyone
here feel threatened about bringing up a
question or a topic or an idea and I
think that that what's that the boys are
the boy of the shirt who came out you
know and he did his thing but does
anyone actually feel like they couldn't
bring it up and I think that that is one
of the problems that I hear from
students at other universities is that
they actually feel they cannot even
raise a question in class that they
could write a paper that was opposite of
their professors views and fail as a
result of it whereas I just I I
fundamentally don't believe that that
happens at this university because this
university does celebrate and believe in
diversity of thought so but it's a great
question thank you we have time for one
final question
okay thank you very much for coming out
again today I appreciate very much how
you ended your speech I was thinking
about that specific comment as you're
doing your whole speak speech as it
relates to something one of the things I
was more or less kind of expecting you
to kind of touch on a little more I
would even go further down the education
realm into the public school systems not
only at the higher education where I see
a lot of issues going or taking place
when I try to instruct my children I
always tell them that there's going to
be a person who has an influencer and
there are those who are easily
influenced as an influencer it's okay -
you're gonna influence someone or
someone could be influenced to do
something good or something bad
as one of those easily influenced they
could be influenced to do what is good
and what is bad the question is
knowing and understanding what is good
and what is bad good point and so when I
go and try to talk with my kids about
that I try to make that clear
distinction and when I address faith
with them wherever God is removed
everything about God tends to be removed
and we try to replace that with policies
so how would you address and bring that
type of a topic up in some of your
writings or in conversations you would
have at your in the journalistic essence
talking about faith
yes bringing that up because you didn't
really touch on faith as being some of
the issues to help guide students as to
what is right and wrong and that tends
to be the the core issue right down from
the early development of children to the
policymakers that we have today yeah it
is fundamentally a problem and it starts
I think at the grade school in public
education level where there are so many
schools that have excised any I mean we
all know this right the public schools
that were no longer allowed to have a
Christmas celebration school or any sort
of reference to anything that involves
faith whatsoever so some of you may not
know this I actually spend my time I
split my time between Washington DC and
my home with my husband in Alaska and we
live in a very conservative community in
Alaska and I was practically shocked
when I went to my first child's choir
concert and the kids busted out in a
rendition of God Bless America in the
public schools I was like wow I like
this place a lot but yeah we have a
situation and we all know this we're too
much of society has forgotten that the
separation of church and state doesn't
mean that you cannot have a church it
means the state's not supposed to impede
on a church's work and we need to reject
that into our culture and society and
look I think there's a couple of really
really uplifting things that we're
seeing out there the Trump
administration and it's campaigns on
behalf of religious freedom are
extraordinary
and and something to celebrate and and
if you didn't see this just the other
day it didn't get enough attention but
they are crafting a new rule to get rid
of a last minute obama prohibition
against faith-based adoptions out there
which has been a terrible terrible thing
so I think that that is you're right
that has got to be part of the
discussion as well too we have gotten so
many things backward in our constitution
in recent years people using you know
maligning and misinterpreting and not
understanding what it was actually there
for that is one of the worst examples of
it the idea that we need to now the
Supreme Court took an itsy-bitsy step in
the right direction with their
Brandenburg cross decision which is very
good but they need to go a lot further
and we need to remind the country and
we're gonna have to look for
institutions like that to lead the way I
think but also colleges and again our
leaders to talk about this stuff more
openly but you're right it's a
fundamental aspect of this and I should
have mentioned it tonight thank you
thank you
you